WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLYK
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLYM
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLYE
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLYL
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLY
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLYU
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLYL
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLYO
WITH KIMBERLY          KIMBERLY,
KATIE PAVLICH.
AS OUR PRESIDENT WELCOMES HIS
FRENCH COUNTERPART, LET'S NOT
FORGET HOW THE MEDIA PORTRAYS
TRUMPS HARMFUL FOREIGN POLICY.
>> REPUBLICANS REALLY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMMINENT THREAT THEY KNOW
BECAUSE THEY'VE SEEN BEHIND THE
SCENES.
THIS MAN POSES TO THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> I HAVE ASKED THE TWITTER
SPOKESMAN, DOESN'T VIOLATE THE
TERMS OF SERVICE, MAKING THIS
KIND OF THREAT TOWARD
NORTH KOREA.
>> ON THE WORLD STAGE, THIS
PRESIDENT IS HUMILIATING
AMERICA, NO QUESTION.
>> Greg: THAT DIDN'T AGE WELL.
DOES THE PRESIDENT OF FRANCE
AGREED?
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE TOGETHER BUT I'M VERY
HONORED AND PLEASED BECAUSE
WHATEVER THE CONTEXT COULD BE,
THIS RELATIONSHIP IS STRONGER.
ON TOP OF IT, WE HAVE AN
EXCELLENT RELATIONSHIP.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> Greg: OUR POOR MEDIA.
THE SOPHISTICATED EUROPEAN DOORS
OUR PRESIDENT.
WHY SHOULDN'T HE?
HE IS ADORABLE.
>> IT'S A GREAT HONOR, GREAT
HONOR TO BE HERE.
WE DO HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP.
I WILL GET THAT LITTLE PIECE OF
DANDRUFF OFF.
WE HAVE TO MAKE HIM PERFECT.
HE IS PERFECT.
>> Greg: OH, MY GOD.
SOMEBODY BREAK OUT THE THERAPY
LLAMAS.
EVERY SINGLE -- IT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TRUMP AND
OBAMA.
OBAMA WAS BELOVED BY THE MEDIA
BUT OUR GLOBAL ADVERSARY SAW HIM
AS A MARK.
TRUMP IS DESPISED BY THE MEDIA
BUT EFFECTIVE ON THE WORLD
STAGE.
LET'S REVIEW THE WORLD STAGE.
ISIS IS MORE THAN HANDLED FOR
NOW.
NORTH KOREA, BOLD MOVES BY TRUMP
MAY CREATE AN HISTORIC THOUGHT.
SYRIA, HE DREW REDLINES.
HE MADE THE HISTORIC VISIT TO
THE HOMES OF EACH MAJOR
RELIGIONS.
RECOGNIZE JERUSALEM AS ISRAEL'S
CAPITAL.
BEHIND IT ALL, HE IS REBUILDING
OUR PRIORITIES ARE THAT.
OBAMA WAS THE SUBSTITUTE TEACHER
YOU COULD SPIN IN SIX DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
TRUMP IS THE SCARY FOOTBALL
COACH WHO RUNS DETENTION.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID ABOUT IRAN.
>> IF IRAN THREATENS US IN ANY
WAY, THEY WILL PAY PRICE LIKE
FEW COUNTRIES HAVE EVER PAID.
>> Greg: WOW.
WHEN TRUMP ANSWERS THE EQUATION,
A RESET TAKES PLACE THAT CREATES
CHAOS BY DESIGN.
AS ANY NEGOTIATOR KNOWS, YOU CAN
PLAN ADVERSARY YOU CAN'T FIGURE
OUT.
TRUMPS GREATEST ASSET, AND
PREDICTABILITY.
AND HE KNOWS IT.
IT'S ONLY OUR MEDIA WHO HASN'T
FIGURED THAT OUT YET.
THEY ARE STILL STUCK ON TRUMPS
SPELLING ERRORS.
PETER, ON THE SCALE OF 1 TO
NOTHING, TO 10.
>> Peter: I WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
KUDOS.
UNPREDICTABILITY IS THE KEY.
WHEN YOU ARE STRONG AND HAVE
CONFIDENCE AND HAVE AMERICAN
POWER, YOUR ADVERSARIES, YOU AND
YOUR ALLIES RESPECT IT.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE IS
A LAYUP.
HE DECIDED TO STAND BY OUR
TRADITIONAL ALLIES AND STAND UP
TO THE ENEMIES OF THE FREE WORLD
TO THE ENEMIES OF THE FREE WORL
WORLD.
WHETHER IT'S CHINA ON TRAIN,
NORTH KOREA, DICTATORS, IRAN.
I THINK HE WILL SCRAP THE IRAN
DEAL IN SPITE OF EMMANUEL
MACRON'S ATTEMPTS TO DO
OTHERWISE.
WE HAVE NOT NEEDED THE FRENCH
SINCE 1775 BUT IT'S NICE TO HAVE
THEM.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO ADMIT
DONALD TRUMP IS THE GREATEST
PRESIDENT THAT EVER LIVED.
>> Juan: HE SAID 11.
I AM LOOKING FOR 12.
MAY BE A BAKER'S DOZEN.
I THINK 13 IS BAD LUCK.
I AM STRUCK BY WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
I THINK ABOUT FOREIGN POLICY AND
I THINK TO MYSELF WAIT A SECOND.
THIS IS A GUY YOU SAY AND FORCED
A REDLINE.
HE WAS SAYING WE SHOULD GET OUT
OF SYRIA.
THEN YOU HAVE A REPUBLICAN
SAYING YOU DON'T WANT TO START
ANY TROUBLE.
HE SUPPOSEDLY ENFORCES A REDLINE
AND THEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE SAYING
IT WAS PRETTY INEFFECTUAL.
HE DIDN'T DO MUCH HERE.
WHAT IS EXACTLY THE STRATEGY.
WE DON'T HAVE A STRATEGY.
THEN I THINK TO MYSELF, LET ME
LISTEN TO GREG.
GREG IS SAYING HE'S A GREAT
FOREIGN POLICY LEADER.
THAT MUST MEAN THAT MACRON HAS
COME ACROSS THE OCEAN AND HE IS
SAYING MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU.
IN FACT TSA YOU ARE WRONG ON THE
HE'S SAYING YOU ARE WRONG ON
TRADE.
HE IS SAYING YOU ARE WRONG ON
SYRIA.
ON THAT ANGELA MERKEL IS COMING
AT THE END OF THE WEEK AND
SAYING, OH, IS HE GOING TO --
SHE IS GOING TO ENFORCE WHAT
MACRON HAS SAID TO TRUMP.
>> Katie: THE THING THAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH THESE
MEETINGS, ADVERSARIES OR ALLIES,
HE ALWAYS FOCUSES ON THE
AGREEMENT FIRST.
AS YOU HAVE SEEN HIM COME
THROUGH THE FIRST YEAR OF HIS
PRESIDENCY, HE'S EMBOLDENED THE
ALLIES.
HE HAS KIND OF DISTANCE HIMSELF
FROM THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TO
NECESSARILY IN OUR INTERESTS.
TURKEY IS ONE OF THOSE EXAMPLES.
WHEN IT COMES TO SYRIA, HE
ADDRESSED THAT TODAY.
TALKED ABOUT THE IRAN DEAL.
I WANT TO GET OUT EVENTUALLY BUT
WE HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANT THE MEDITERRANEAN,
AS HE SAID, TO BE A FREE-FOR-ALL
FOR THE IRANIANS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE IRAN DEAL,
I ALSO BELIEVE BASED ON THE
PRESIDENT'S RHETORIC IN THE PAST
FEW MONTHS AND ALSO TODAY HE
SAID IT WAS BUILT ON A DECAYING
FOUNDATION.
THAT'S THE LANGUAGE.
HE'S TELLING US HE'S GOING TO
SCRAP IT.
IF THE AGREEMENT, THERE IS
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT HOW TO FIX IT
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT HOW TO FIX I
IT.
>> Kimberly: THEY ARE GOING TO
TAG TEAM HIM A LITTLE BIT.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WAS A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
CHARM AND WARMTH AND THEY SEEM
TO GET ALONG.
BESIDES THE DANDRUFF COMMENT.
THEY GET ALONG WELL WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
GROOMING EACH OTHER.
>> Juan: THE PROBLEM IS SHE'S
CALLING OUT THE GUY FOR HAVING
DANDRUFF.
>> Kimberly: YEAH, IT'S A
LITTLE BIT --
ANYWAY.
THE FRENCH DON'T MIND.
THEY HAVE A GLASS OF WINE AND
THEY FORGET ALL ABOUT IT.
NOW ANGELA MERKEL HAS BEEN QUITE
CRITICAL OF THE PRESIDENT BUT
SHE'S GOING TO HAVE TO ROLL IT
BACK A LITTLE BIT IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO GET DIPLOMACY.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
RECONSIDER THE IRAN NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT AND HE WANTS THEM TO
GET INVOLVED AND GO ALONG WITH
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO AS IT
RELATES TO SYRIA AND IRAN IN
TERMS OF THE GEOPOLITICAL AREA
STRIFE WITH PROBLEMS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
IN TERMS OF THAT, HE'S ALREADY
GOTTEN SOME KIND OF NEGOTIATING
TRIP.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PLAY
BALL.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
RESPECTFUL.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO STOP WITH
THE INCESSANT CRITICISM.
SHE IS NO LONGER THE IRON LADY
THAT SHE WAS.
SHE HAS BEEN TREMENDOUSLY
WEAKENED POLITICALLY ACROSS
EUROPE WITH THE PROBLEMS SHE'S
HAD THERE IN TERMS OF THE
ELECTIONS ET CETERA.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS AT THE END OF
THE WEEK.
>> Katie: I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN A LITTLE
BIT OF PRESSURE OFF THE
EUROPEANS BY CALLING ON THE ARAB
NATIONS AROUND IRAN WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NUCLEAR
PROGRAM, THEY HAVE THREATENED TO
RESTART IT.
HE IS SAYING THIS IS YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY IN YOUR REGION
WHICH ALLOWS THE EUROPEANS TO
STEP BACK AND SAY IT'S IN OUR
INTEREST TO BE INVOLVED WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
RULES ARE BEING FOLLOWED ARE THE
PEOPLE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> Peter: REASSERTED THE REAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN US AND THE
EUROPEAN NATIONS.
BARACK OBAMA WAS DEFERENTIAL TO
THESE COUNTRIES.
>> Greg: WE WERE INFERIOR.
>> Peter: YOU LOOK AT FRANCE.
THEY HAVE GUIDED THEIR MILITARY
TO PAY FOR THEIR WELFARE STATE.
THEY'VE OPEN THEIR BORDERS.
THEY HAVE TERRORISM PROBLEMS,
DEMOGRAPHIC PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE TO THE WORLD POWER THEY
USED TO BE.
-- THEY AREN'T THE WORLD POWER
THEY USED TO BE.
HE IS WIPING OFF THE DANDRUFF,
PATTING THEM ON THE SHOULDER.
>> Katie: I DO NOT HAVE
DANDRUFF.
FOR THE RECORD.
>> Greg: IN FRANCE, THEY CALL
IT SHOULDER SNOW.
>> Kimberly: JUAN IS LIKE,
WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
TRUMP MADE YOU LAUGH TODAY.
>> Juan: ACTUALLY I WAS HOPING
I WOULD GET SOME LLAMA.
I UNDERSTAND THEY ARE HAVING
LAMB.
I AM GLAD HE'S DRAINING THE
SWAMP OF THESE ELITISTS.
LAMB CHOPS AT A STATE DINNER.
NOT A BIG STATE DINNER, TINY
STATE DINNER.
I LOVE IT.
NEXT TIME.
JESSE IS NOT HERE.
YOU NEED SOMEBODY.
>> Greg: GOING AFTER SPELLING
AND FOOD.
JUAN, I WANT TO SHOW YOU HOW
SPECIAL THIS RELATIONSHIP IS.
EVERY WORLD LEADER WHEN THEY
MEET TRUMP, THEY COME AWAY WITH
A SPECIAL FEELING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> I LIKE HIM A LOT.
IT'S AN HONOR TO CALL YOU MY
FRIEND.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: IT IS A BUDDY COMEDY.
>> Juan: THE MOVIE WITH THE
COPS.
"48 HOURS."
THE PROBLEM HERE, THE BIG
PROBLEM IS YOU HAVE MACRON IN
THE EUROPEANS.
YOU SOUND LIKE DON RUMSFELD, OLD
EUROPE.
EUROPE, GUESS WHAT, AS MACRON
HAS SAID, THE UNITED STATES
NEEDS ALLIES.
>> Katie: WE HAVE ALLIES.
>> Juan: THEY ARE OUR
PRINCIPAL ALLIES ESPECIALLY THE